[Applause]
[Music]
what a great catch that was Jerry
unbelievable behind him I mean that make
it the best power 26 or so does have
Cass beat McCallum go out of control
here's holiday and the breakaway here
comes the double
cousins cousins for the win
[Applause]
another love decision here the markers
really have no opportunity except you
has to get the ball up to basket and out
not that sweet roll as it will rings
into the hoop and the team's gonna win
another look at it
wall dependent fadeaway jump shot just
get up
[Applause]
big cars and the King listens
anticipated it beautifully here's cuz
nice pass to cast
[Applause]
the ball drop ball past the castle
minute of this game possess what a shot
by to Marcos cousins yet that is
remarkable the Pistons couldn't have
played it defensively any better 17
shootings
[Music]
[Applause]
now cousins and put it in the book and
send them to the line cousins has their
pain in a chance for 14-4 come running a
danger home takes the seat Spencer Hawes
and in the land both trying to do
something inside but they can't help on
the because in this first half Hill in
Sacramento California and the Kings are
up by 10 why are you missing that
Rockies Laker game how was they bowed to
him someone cut me off
[Music]
[Applause]
you see right here is the big boy moving
you have to tell everybody welcome to
the league at some point I'm sure
porzingis is going to be able to do that
in his own time cousins
oohs and aahs from the crowd here in
Oakland goes way now watch DeMarcus
Cousins and it's kind of like get out of
my way
Wow hey let me tell you secret everybody
did get out of his way watch this watch
the white shirts a separate because
major women shot Koufos looking they're
fine cousins DeMarcus Cousins have you
don't like that you don't like NBA
basketball he took off from the foul
line and throw it down with authority
who first gets the ball here comes cuz
you see the white shirts only CamLAN
painted in here and Serge Ibaka even
thought I don't need any part
this watch pain just run by as because
as women and jamming and boy that was
major Duncan who's gonna take this shot
cousins right to the rim but you'll
you're trying to catch up he can't cuz
what the left hand and the left hand
finish big boogie the true boogie man
for the Dallas Mavericks
how many bigs can do this I got your
answer
only one and you're looking at rebound
this family nice little dump passed down
easy six Collison what a pass cousins
will account yes cousins running the
floor is tremendous now watch cousins
here follow up this play and that's
going to count
boy that is big-time hustle by cousins
to follow up the missed by Darren
Collison they'll review it but that is a
good basket
[Music]
Ibaka's Cossacks
4740
[Music]
and he stepped out and knocks down an
18-foot part missed by a foot cousins
[Applause]
has the basket buh-buh-buh-buh his
cousin's 26:18 [ __ ] cousins look at
that move for the big fella
[Music]
wench low
Hassan Whiteside block my cousin's into
the hands of rudy gay boi perfectly time
blah fences like you know put backs on
garbage you know yeah he does he can't
spot you to 15-footer although he hasn't
had any of those but really the kings
really know and when he gets around the
basket rebound taken by elusive it
cousins with a steal he'll go right at
loose of its big step and and send the
to the line what up gifted gifted play
bits of the double whammy get bad past
cousins picks it off then goes right
back a demon end me up another doll
stick contact cuz you said that's the
big death this is your six eleven
270-pounder Jill showing you some
[Applause]
Timofey Mozgov here checking his ankles
and you're wondering is this a charger
nod Nick Young moving at the last minute
let's get Tech good call
[Applause]
and cousins ties the game at 106 with
9.7 left boy and now how about this
Power Move in traffic gets the shooters
roboy cuz five points couldn't cousins
he
[Applause]
better see the Euro step out of Center
and then the halfcourt
Eve talk about a skill pick just simply
too much of everything the fact he's
shooting the three so well you see
Hamilton come out run at him and that
like gives presence a chance to beat him
off the bounce so one thing helps the
other can you establish the perimeter
game it makes it easier to get to the
basket no doubt
DeMarcus crossing over to Marcus to the
basket and it dumped by cousins and put
it in the book and send them to the line
with 15.8 here in the hand it just looks
like don't take it three crosses over if
the second defender comes the third
defender comes and it's smushed I'm
cousins Ville oh look 18 to 4 difference
in points off journals you favor the
Kings
dribble Musial 20 beats him immediately
the spacing is good so the second
defender can't get it with shooting of
the Clippers jury they've made 11 over
the last 19 three-point attempts
discussions
Magic Johnson vault right there a lot of
gorgeous look history what just
threatened to meet over the shoulder
hits the 11th Street peasants good move
what no fight DeMarcus Cousins watch his
beautiful up and under what body control
look at Cunningham front cousins here's
the double by Davis who's open
[Music]
Matt Barnes why I don't know if he can
pass the pole any better than DeMarcus
Cousins just
played here with the pelicans he's from
Mobile Alabama spent his first six
seasons with another prolific on board
and grid of the play cousins on the path
unbelievable behind the fact that Dante
Cunningham timeout portlet whatever it
takes
behind the back oh yeah oh yeah pull out
the hot dogs we got a party good stuff
after this day off Mentos pers cousins
crossover all the way to the
you like going lower that dribble
[Applause]
reaction to this all too big whoa what
am I supposed to do with that so hard
looking and looking for contacts with
the looking for backdoor run Bethany
blocks it away
played by DeMarcus here you're gonna
really posterized me dropper Draper
three will live
and it wasn't close
now she's gotta go it will three the
buzzer
good recognition by DeMarcus Cousins to
go through the break with a triple and
16 and 9 with 5 assists in the house not
a bad start that's good stuff for the
pelicans get out of this half with a 12
point lead that a special in the way the
two teams started the game offensive ly
4 seconds 3 done locked by Davis numbers
to the trailer is present he never got
to Cunningham
before a deeper three tough break
now the run-out burn levity towns clock
to of hydaburg
they bargain they have a good
conversation he talked it he talked to
every town midranges where he excels the
markets doing a great job
[Applause]
[Music]
goodnight 80 with both hands Mugi
tossing it all the way down
David's with the finish little bit
boogey man ADEs back on the floors green
clears it out
so the pelicans down now to 39% what a
plot to Marcus cousins up top to deep
and then that's it that's a really good
recovery by cousin Senate matumbo a
green fours that piss they're looking
for transition the call ended up fake
going higher than to tie puzzles
better sharing with each one more pays
off first but what about the bottle drew
so it's his third bucket on his third
try he's got eight holiday with cousins
[Applause]
cousins is up to 17 there's four in that
many points attacking the clothes out
throw the hammer Dennis Smith junior
Rondo back on the floor at a clear path
for DeMarcus Cousins power card to the
hole the car light refreshing finish man
he went right through the arm of flavor
and in that category really the
difference in the game
holiday try to get it going on it again
nerf it's the recipient of that one
[Music]
super awesome it was definitely you we
looked at the cameras the cookie
LaRhonda he's long ago
[Music]
and that's what the Pels are doing -
that goes right down and you have a
taste for a meal like this it's hard to
help and right now if he's putting his
head down and he's determined to get to
the basket my goodness I'm not sure what
you do with that stay out of the way now
on the switch and bogey a move hammers
it three-point game
Rondo is waiting just moved and then
nice backdoor run and I wasn't really
thinking dunk that I was thinking lay it
out to meet the whole team the whole
Lake our approach became much the
Hudsons throws it down and stands over
for smoke a whistle and the foul Luke
Walton wanted a charge I think kruseman
was in the restricted area technical
free throw misses
[Applause]
[Music]
that's that has to be what it is that's
his third technical as a member of the
Warriors one of them came early this
year when he was in street clothes I
didn't think that was that cousins did
want that tre initially
[Applause]
facility for a three-point play
hesitation oh and he did that with the
left hand the whole way
is a move from the guard you roll in one
way and you're rolling back on the same
hand once he got bite on says Jim look
at all the resistance he beat a smaller
player on a move throw it in the Bayou
good point
Oh with the hammer and the foul welcome
back to New Orleans what's up you guys
this Taylor Brooks with bleacher report
make sure that you subscribe for some
more video content